If then you have been raised with Christ,
seek the things that are above where Christ is seated at the right hand of God.
Set your minds on things that are above, not on things that are on earth
For you have died and your life is hidden with Christ in God.
When Christ who is your life appears,
then you will also appear with him in glory.
Well, good morning, church, family. Uh,
we did not anticipate having a family worship gathering today, but, uh,
here we are.
And so I know that brings with it a little trepidation for some of you.
It also brings with it some excitement for some of you and some chaos for some
of you. And so, uh, let's just get this outta the way first. Uh,
if you don't have kids here and you're just here because you're here, hey,
let's pray and let's have a focus that God would work in your life
and all the things that you wanted today and, and needed today,
he'll give that to you. But also encourage those around you,
you who do have kids, right?
And so let's not give the side eye glance at somebody. Let's not do that. Uh,
this is not anything but what they've done for thousands of years in any church
gathering. Okay? Uh, also parents, lemme talk to you for a second. It's okay.
All right, let's, okay. Uh, if your kid makes noise,
your kid needs to get up and walk around and do some things, that's fine. Uh,
we're not against that by any means. And then kids,
let me talk to you for a second. I know you can hang with me, okay?
I've talked to you in kids area a couple times over the years. I've,
I've been with you. We, we can hang together, okay? We can do this. All right?
You can focus.
We're gonna walk through God's word a little bit and I know you can follow
along. Okay?
And so let's all agree that this is gonna be a great morning as it already has
been, as we've seen this as we go. Alright?
So we are going through the book of Colossians,
and in the study we've had so far, we see these,
these structures of letters show up, especially here as an example.
And so there was a introduction of names.
There was a Thanksgiving section today,
as most letters is gonna be a prayer. And so that's the prayer from Paul.
We're gonna study in Colossians, chapter one. So take your copy, God's word,
turn there with me. Colossians chapter one. If you don't have one,
it'll be on the screen or there may be one in this half of the room under the
seats in front of you. We haven't yet got to this side. Sorry, they're on the,
the big, uh, blocks over there if you need one. Uh,
also next week we're gonna pause on Colossians and Labor Day weekend,
jump into Psalms again. Then we'll come back after that two Colossians.
But today we're gonna study what God's word has to say about prayer
and of anything in our faith for, for me included.
This tends to be the one that we are the weakest at most of us struggle with
prayer, how to do it, where we do it, when we do it, all those things.
Most people would say they're not good at prayer.
Why is it so difficult to practice? Why is this the one that is the hardest?
Well, part of the reason is because we stay on the surface with God,
with him theologically, we, we, we really don't understand him deeply.
And so that's where our prayers land.
Just think about how often our prayers,
our petitions deal with things like good health, recovery from illness,
safety on the road as on a test, and so on.
That's kind of where we, we stay up there.
But when you really start to read the Bible,
how many of the prayers recorded in scripture have to do with any of those
things at all?
Like very few actually deal with those kinds of things.
It seems like in our prayer lives, as we look at that, it,
it seems like we've become no different than the pagans that Paul
was writing this letter about to the church in Colossae.
We've become no different than those pagans who were focused solely on physical,
tangible pleasure. Can life be easy?
That's essentially where our prayer lives go. But here's, here's the reality,
here's the point. Kids, if you walk away with nothing else,
here's what I want you to remember. What we pray for is what our priorities are.
Just think about that.
Like what we pray for is what our priorities are
in life.
So when you think about what we pray for is our greatest desire,
our health and wealth and comfort,
is that what we are always praying for?
Or is there more to life?
Is there more to eternity that we should be praying for?
That's why we need this passage today because it's gonna help us answer what
true solid Christ above all prayer would look like.
So let's see how God's word leads us to pray.
Colossians one verses nine through 14 is where we'll be today.
He continues this letter to the Colossians, he says,
and so from the day we heard, we have not ceased to pray for you.
Asking.
You may be filled with the knowledge of his will in all spiritual wisdom and
understanding so as to walk in a manner worthy of the Lord,
fully pleasing to him,
bearing fruit in every good work and increasing in the knowledge of God,
being strengthened with all power according to his glorious might for all
endurance and patience with joy giving thanks to the Father who has
qualified you or some manuscripts us to share in the inheritance of the saints
in light, he has delivered us from the domain of darkness,
transferred us to the kingdom of his beloved son in whom we have redemption,
the forgiveness of sins. God help us see this.
We need this as it says,
spiritual wisdom and understanding to know what you have for us every age here
today to hear something and know about prayer better than we started.
But God, that's your work. This is your fruit to bear in our lives.
Grow us in your will for your glory. In Jesus' name.
Amen. And so if you remember,
Paul had most likely never met these people, these writing to,
and so he'd heard from Eris,
the local that that they had received the gospel,
it bear fruit in their lives. It was increasing.
And so Paul heard that he began praying. The word is constantly now.
Now don't think 24 7, like you have to be always in prayer like that, but,
but think more regularly interceding for them. That's the word we get from this.
Think of the way someone might pray for a wayward child.
It's not 24 7, but it is constant, right? It's, it's on your mind.
It's consistent. It's never giving up. Like in Luke 18,
the widow pounding on the judge's door all night, give me justice.
That's kinda the idea we get here of constant prayer.
But notice for Paul,
the prayer he's talking about is not just when hardship comes, like when,
when we pray, we typically have something bad happen.
And then we pray immediately because of that, he's praying for things.
Notice how he started verse nine. And so,
or maybe your translation for this reason,
he's praying for things he just gave thanks for. He says, guys,
this is what I see in your life. This is exciting to watch God work.
And so I'm praying for those things more and more in your life, right?
He's praying for things that that he's just given thanks for. So it's,
it's more of an ongoing prayer, more of a, a thing that he's praying for,
not needs as much as he is for these concerns he has that they would grow in
their faith. That's one of our values here as a church is desperate dependence.
And we're not talking about just whenever we know things are falling apart or
when things are hard.
We're talking about all the time that this is God's work to do, not ours.
So he's saying that for them in their lives,
not just when cancer comes in your life.
Pray constantly for your growth and others' growth as well.
So notice what he says to pray for then if that's what we are to do.
This section's a great example of what we should prioritize and prayer.
'cause what you pray for is what you priorities are.
So first he says you should pray for others' spiritual knowledge.
These are the things he mentions here that,
that he's praying for them that we can model and pray as well.
Spiritual knowledge. By the way,
it might seem like I'm talking a lot about praying for other people here because
that's the way Paul's talking. He's praying for another group of people.
You can pray this stuff for yourself too. Don't think you can't, right? In fact,
you probably should.
But here's the question I want to ask you before we get into this.
Are you even praying for other people
or are your prayers only self-focused? It's all about you.
Let's make sure and and follow Paul's example here and pray for others as well.
Your brothers and sisters in Christ that you're praying for their spiritual
growth as we see Paul do here.
But look again, verse nine. He says,
he's asking that they may be filled with the knowledge of God's will and all
spiritual wisdom and understanding. And so Paul's praying for them.
We ought to pray for others to grow in their mental capacity,
to understand who God is and what He's done
that like it says in Ephesians chapter three,
that they may have strength to comprehend with all the saints,
what is the bra breadth and length and height and depth and to know the
love of Christ that surpasses knowledge that you may be filled with all the
fullness of God. Remember, what was the context?
The Colossian Christians were constantly faced with the noise of
false religions all around them of other ways to get to
a God. This person was saying this, this and others saying this over here.
Or they were hearing this and this or ways to be satisfied in life.
They're hearing all of these things around them.
And so they needed to know what Yahweh, God Almighty said.
They needed to know what he said about them, what he said about life,
what he said about truth and faith.
They needed to lean into what's Paul writes in one Corinthians two,
this mind of Christ,
they needed to lean into that so they can know and discern what is of God,
what's not of God, what to do about it. Listen,
it is no different for us today, right?
Your Facebook feed, your TikTok feed, C n N, Fox News,
they're all presenting a lot of information to you.
And it's not all true. It's not all true.
It's constantly putting in front of you information,
getting you to focus on this or focus on that.
And you and I need the Holy Spirit's wisdom to know what's truth and what's not.
The Colossians, we're getting it. We're getting it as well.
And so we ought to be praying that God grows our minds,
that we can be aware and understand His will.
Understand how he wants us to live. As Romans 12,
two says, do not be conformed to this world,
but be transformed by the renewal of your mind.
That by testing you may discern what is the will of God.
What is good and acceptable and perfect?
Are you praying that for anyone else?
Are you praying those words for yourself at all?
Listen, I look around and I know in my life and our lives,
there's a famine of spiritual understanding in our world right now.
And so we need to un on our faces,
pray that God would bring spiritual understanding to our lives so we can know
what to do.
We must not cease praying for things like that.
But Paul also understood this like the rest of the New Testament also
understands this. That our faith is not merely intellectual.
It's not just that we know that we understand,
it does involve our minds, but it's intended to lead us to something.
This is Colossians one, verse 10.
It says So as,
so he just talked about praying for knowledge and spiritual understanding so as
to walk in a manner worthy of the Lord fully pleasing to him,
right? You see that
the reason Paul was praying for their minds to grow was so that their life would
change.
Not just that they would go puffed up like kinda megamind growing your brain
more and more. Like that's not what he's talking about.
He's talking about so that your life would change,
you know more so you can do more Knowledge leads to action.
We ought to pray for others wise life, application of the wisdom of God.
This word, he says, walk here, your walk.
This word is used all over scripture to refer to the way we live as we follow
the Lord. I actually had a, in the first church I started,
I had a new believer get confused by that word. I asked him,
I didn't even think about it 'cause I'm just kind of in the culture. I like,
how's your walk doing? He's like, uh, like bouncy, I guess.
I don't know. And I dunno, I limp a little bit. He had no idea.
It's talking about your faith. It's talking about the way you live your life,
that the word walk is referring to the way you live in
light of God's work in your life, how you're following him.
And so we see here we are to walk in a manner worthy
of the Lord. And that worthy of the Lord is,
is what is pleasing to the Lord. Now, wait a second here.
Kids, you might have even picked this up. Like if we're supposed to please God,
does that mean that we can earn God's love in some way?
Good answer said no. No.
This has nothing to do with salvation.
This has nothing to do with good works that would earn God's love.
It's kind of like with your kids parents when,
when you're thinking about how you will love your children unconditionally
forever, no questions asked. Like that's just the way it is.
You're modeling God's love for you to your kids. Nothing will ever change that.
That is what we are about. But when you watch one of them serve,
when you hear of the way that they treat their teachers at school really
positively when they're writing notes to someone that's an encouraging note or
or they're resisting a sin very clearly and you hear of that or you watch
them do that, man, that just lifts your spirit as a parent, doesn't it?
Like it makes you proud, it pleases you.
So it doesn't change your love,
but it it pleases you in the way you respond to them.
And so that's what he's talking about here. And so we need to know, okay,
what does a life that pleases the Lord look like?
If that's what we're called to, what does it look like?
What does the sorts of things we can be praying for in others' lives,
in our own lives? Well,
he gives a series here of three les that describe a life that pleases
the Lord.
The first one he says is that we should pray that fruit would be produced in
someone's life, A life that pleases.
God is a life that bears fruit in every good work. Verse 10 says,
we already saw last week in verse six that that's what this gospel word of hope
does. When it takes root in someone's life, it increasingly bears fruit.
It produces something when the gospel changes you.
And so the fruit of the spirit is love, joy, peace, patience, kindness,
goodness, faithfulness, gentleness, self-control. Galatians five says,
that's fruit of the spirit working in you. Yes, but notice here,
Paul ties it to every good work,
bearing fruit in every good work. Not good works that could save you,
but responsive works that please God
Generous
Works that he is designed for us to fulfill,
which is actually what Ephesians two 10 says, that we are his workmanship,
his masterpiece, his creation,
created in Christ Jesus for good works,
which God prepared beforehand that we should walk in them,
Right? Not for salvation, it's in response to salvation.
These good works come up.
And you remember we studied this back in the winter in Titus,
that Titus two says that God's grace trains us to be
zealous for good works.
That something in us as God plants his gospel,
changes our hearts to want to do things that Titus two and three says that we
should turn from sin. We should live self-controlled,
godly lives in our thoughts, in our actions.
We should submit to authorities speak evil of no one.
Avoid quarreling, be gentle. Respect all people, not gossip.
Don't stir up division.
That's what Titus two and three says is a life that pleases God,
a life that is full of good works. Those kinds of things.
It's what Jesus said, John 15, if you obey his commandments,
you will abide in his love when you abide in Jesus.
That's what he says later that that's where good fruit comes.
If you abide in me, you'll produce fruit.
So abiding comes through obedience to his commands. That's the good works,
which then in turn produces fruits through our lives.
So you think about how do I obey what? What am I supposed to obey?
It's God's command. So think about if you would love an enemy,
The fruit that comes from that of course changes you.
But it could also change that person's heart.
And their heart is softened to something that you couldn't do on your own.
You obey God's command to give sacrificially to a needy brother and
sister around you in the church they're provided for. That's the fruit, right?
You.
You think about showing mercy to a stranger in this room that you don't know,
but they're sitting by themselves and you can tell something as you're seeing
with God's eyes and you show mercy to them as God commanded they are
what? The fruit is there welcomed and loved by that.
And you could go on and on and on. As we obey God's word.
He produces fruit through us.
So are you praying that yourself and others around you would bear more
fruit? Are you asking God for it?
Are you positioning yourself to abide in him better so that you produce more
fruit as God does it through you?
Those are ways to pray.
That's not all though a life that pleases the Lord is that it bears
fruit. Verse 10, yes. But also that it grows in the knowledge of God.
A life that pleases the Lord is one that grows in the knowledge of God,
that their in their knowledge will be increased.
We've already talked a lot about this, but see this
scripture is very clear that growing in the depth of your understanding is
part of a life that pleases God.
I know firsthand how easy it is to get complacent and to get
lazy in your pursuit of the Lord.
I know how easy it is to slip into this reality that if you've been in church
for a long time, that you think you know everything already
and you can think and feel like I don't need to grow.
I don't need anything else.
How wrong a perspective though?
But listen, here's the reality I found in varieties of ways in my life.
God won't let you stay there. You start to think,
I've got it all figured out. I know this. I don't need what they're offering.
I don't need the word. I don't need to pray. I don't need the basics anymore.
He won't let you stay there.
He'll take you to a place of brokenness or to
a wilderness season in life
Where
You're gonna have to learn some things.
And why does he do that? Because he's good. Yeah,
because he's good and he's good because he wants more of you.
He wants more of you.
He wants more of your heart and he wants to reveal more of himself to you,
more of his nature, more of his character,
and in ways that you can only learn through the wilderness season.
So he's good to you to take you through that when you were over here kind of
righteously thinking, I've got it all together.
He takes you through some brokenness so you learn more about him.
'cause here's the reality,
we're always in learning mode with God because he's infinite.
And we're not even when we get to heaven forever, we'll be in learn mode.
'cause we won't be able to know anything more.
Like we can't know everything about God. He's God, we're not.
So that's where we can always grow in this kind of knowledge.
Pray for others towards that end.
Pray for yourself even help other,
we talk a lot about disciple making around here.
That's what we're talking about.
Just help others grow in their knowledge and understanding and application of
God. That's it.
Just help 'em know and help 'em grow in that and pray for your own faith as
well. So that's two.
There's a third here that describes a God pleasing life.
It's in verse 11,
being strengthened with all power according to his glorious might for
all endurance and patience with joy.
So here's what we need to pray for.
Pray with Paul that endurance would be provided by God.
Pray that endurance is provided.
There's so much in this verse really,
but I tried to boil it down to that one word endurance because I think it
encompasses the rest of the verse. That in order to endure
Through false religions pressing on you in colossae or
to endure through pain and suffering in life,
or to endure through temptations that would come constantly in your life,
how do you endure? You need these things.
This verse talks about you need to be strengthened by the Lord's dynamic
power.
That's a power that's not just kind of strength and and muscles.
It's a power according to God's miracle working might,
that God can only do certain things we can't do.
That's his power and might working in us.
Yet you'll also need patience to endure what you face because so much of life is
not resolved in an instant. You gotta have some patience to walk through this,
yet you're to endure with joy.
It says that even through the tears and the aches, you see something better.
You see something out there that's a future and a hope.
That's why all of this goes together. It ties together. Endurance is the word,
but you need strength and power and you need patience.
You need joy all together as endurance.
But when you and I think of our prayer lives,
this is one major way that deviates from what God's word has just said,
Because we so frequently pray that God would
remove someone from the pain, from the situation,
from the persecution, whatever,
like we want God to take it all away.
But are we ever praying for endurance
for that person as they walk through whatever it is are.
Are we praying for God's strength, for God's power to work? Are we,
are we praying that they would show joy through the pain?
Or are we only praying like the pagans in Colossae
that life would be easy for 'em, that life would be easy for us?
Listen to how James chapter one verse 12 writes, it says,
blessed is the man who remains steadfast under trial
for when he has stood the test. He will receive the crown of life,
which God has promised to those who love him.
Just a few verses earlier,
he wrote that we should count it as joy when we face trials because that
joy brings about endurance and that endurance leads to that
steadfastness that brings the crown of life.
And so we should not see it as a problem when we face trials.
We should see it as as a blessing. James says,
because then you get endurance that you never could get any way else
If and only if
you lean on God's strength through the trial.
So let's pray a little bit differently, right? Let, let's pray.
Yes, for healing, for protection, for needs to be met.
God's word commands us to pray for those things.
We're not saying it's wrong to pray for those things,
but let's pray with this kind of perspective
as well as we pray for, for healing,
let's pray for joy and endurance and strength through it.
That's what God's word says to pray for.
But if you remember this passage, if I, as I read it earlier,
you remember now that that we're not through with his prayer yet, right?
We haven't hit all of it because in verse 12,
there's a shift he makes where he begins to include himself in the
prayer.
He starts using us instead of just you,
you Colossians, here's what I'm praying for you.
But then he shifts to this us mentality and he does that because his prayer
turns into a beautiful explanation of eternal salvation.
Like this is what his mind shifts to where he starts to include himself
because he's included in that as salvation as well. He says, no,
this is where we have been included.
And he can't help but praise God.
Even as he's speaking these words to whoever's writing him down, he's saying,
here's what I can't get over
This reality of salvation. I mean,
just look at how the work of God spills out of his mouth.
Do. Do you pray like this?
Like do you see what we're gonna see here in a second? Do you pray like this?
Are these kinds of things in your prayers at all?
Is it only I need this, I need this, I need this. Do this God do this,
God are this, these kinds of things in there.
First in verse 12, he says,
we ought to praise the Father because he's provided an inheritance for us
that God has qualified us to share in the inheritance of the saints in
light.
What that word qualified means is that he's made us sufficient to receive it.
We couldn't before,
but now he's made us sufficient by including us in his family,
by faith. Okay, what's the inheritance we're waiting for?
What is this that he's talking about?
It's what we saw in verse five that he's laid up this hope in heaven for
us.
That's the inheritance that someday we're gonna be with Jesus forever.
That treasure that we've been waiting on,
that he's waiting for the reunion to come.
We're gonna be with the saints in light.
We're gonna be in the light of Jesus forever.
That's the inheritance He's talking about Like what a gift, right?
What a gift that that. This is the absolute.
I know you've maybe got some good gifts in life.
You're waiting on inheritance from a family member. Whatever it is,
this is by far the best inheritance you could ever imagine made even
better because you don't deserve it.
And he's adopted you into his family. He's chosen you. You are his beloved,
simply because he loves you and pulled you in and said your mind.
Praise God for that, right?
And praise the Father that he's also delivered us from darkness. Paul says,
he's not only given us this inheritance that we wait for,
he's delivered us from darkness.
It's all about eternal salvation, right?
This is the new exodus that God accomplished in salvation where he delivered us
out of slavery.
The location we came from is this darkness.
And that idea is used all over scripture to refer to where we are when we're
still lost. Darkness is where we are when we're still in our sin,
when we're in the domain of the enemy,
when we're owned and controlled by our sin, nature, by the enemy himself.
That's the darkness.
It's what Ephesians six 12 says, this present darkness.
And it refers to a spiritual world directed by rulers, authorities,
powers and forces of evil.
That is the darkness that we see creep into the world around us.
And it's the darkness that you and I live in, in our sin.
Yet
believers can look at all of that and we can praise the Lord because
in Christ, he has delivered us.
He has rescued us from the chains of that dark prison cell and we're not
there anymore. Like listen, the the, you remember one Peter two, nine,
this has been years ago. We talked about this in the judges series.
One Peter two, nine says, you are a chosen race. This is why we should worship.
You're a chosen race, a royal priesthood, a holy nation,
a people for his own possession,
that you may proclaim the excellencies of him who called you out of darkness
into his marvelous light,
that he's taken us out of that and made us completely
new. That's why we worship.
Listen, if you've repented and believed in Jesus,
you are not in darkness anymore, but you are in the light of Christ.
Remember who you are, Christian man.
The enemy wants to toss that in you really quickly. No, no. That's who you are.
You are your past. You are what you used to do.
You are who you still get tempted by. Like that's who you are. No, no, no, no.
You're not in darkness anymore. He's delivered you from the domain of darkness.
You are in the light of Christ. Now, that should spark worship and response
And it should lead us to walk as children of light,
a life that pleases God,
a life that is in light now.
But not only has God delivered us out of something, as good as that is,
he's delivered us into something as well. Let me read these verses again,
verses 13 and 14. 'cause it shows it.
He has delivered us from the domain of darkness and transferred us
to the kingdom of his beloved son in whom we have redemption,
the forgiveness of sins.
So he's delivered us out of the domain of darkness and he's transferred us into
the kingdom, his kingdom of of his son,
the redeemed kingdom, the new kingdom.
He's taken us out and put us in.
He's made a way for us to be part of his kingdom.
This new redeemed humanity that is forever and ever. That starts today.
It's not even finished yet, but it one day will be
like these verses. Just think about this. There's a reason I read those. Again,
these verses are the core of salvation, aren't they?
That
Our sins are forgiven through the shed blood of Jesus as our sacrifice.
That he's our substitute that is at the core.
That God paid a ransom of his son's life to free
enslaved sinners like you and me.
And because we could never earn our way out of it, he had to do it.
And simply because he loves he did it.
The redemption that redeemed is freeing from slavery to something else.
It's what Jesus did.
That's the essence of the gospel church,
and it's one primary reason we ought to lift up our voices and praise in here.
And it's why we ought to lift up our lives in pleasing God out there
because of what he's done.
But notice it should also change the way you pray as well.
Do you recount the gospel like that in your prayers?
And do you consider and base all your requests
on the sovereign good hand of God who's done this?
Listen, maybe you don't know how to do that. That's okay.
You've never been shown how you've never been trained,
how there's tons of resources we could point you to to help you pray in this
kind of way. Just come ask.
That's all we'd we'd be able to do is just point you to some good resources.
But even better than that, here's another encouragement.
Get around somebody who does pray like that and just pray with them.
Like think about how did Timothy learn how to pray?
He would just with Paul all the time, Paul's praying like this.
So how did Timothy learn how to pray just like this?
So get around someone who knows how to pray and just listen and learn
and grow in your own ability to pray these kinds of things, as Paul does.